so holten die story ich war gerade beim
zahnarzt und wir gerade gesehen habe
wurde gebohrt und wird dass ich alles an
meinen zähnen und damit ich das ganze
nicht merken und keine schmerzen habe
habe ich vorher eine fette spritze
bekommen
die war ein bisschen zu fett deswegen
habe ich noch höher
ich lag gerade auf beiden seiten also
ich kriege meine lippe die seite hier
ist total taub nur für euch daher schon
mal die vorwarnung falls dem heutigen
video irgendwie lachen sollte das geht
dann nur auf der rechten seite
allerdings will ich sagen fangen wir
jetzt auch direkt mit dem heutigen video
thema an und zwar machen wir heute dass
nur zwei prozent aller menschen schaffen
diese fünf rätselt witz video
der kleine mark und seine eltern sind
samstagabend zu hause seine eltern
beschließen doch noch mal weg ins kino
zu bieten lassen ihren kleinen markt
also zurück wenn sie wiederkommen ist er
tot
[Applaus]
[Musik]
marc decker wo bist du verrückt ich
brauche erstmal ganz kurz meine detektiv
brille weitergeht detektivbüros gerührt
von der geschichte von diesem vorfall
und kommt schleunigst zum tatort
er findet direkt drei verdächtige die
allesamt zugang zum haus hatten in
besagter nacht wenn die eltern weiß man
dass sie sicher im kino waren und nicht
mit drin steckt die hausfrau sagt sie
war eine neue geschmacksrichtung für den
wasserspender noch kaufen ok baumarkt
hatte noch bis 22 uhr offen
der wasserspender wieder leer war doch
dass sie gut wenn sie schon mal aufhört
dann wenig mit einer neuen
geschmacksrichtung der gärtner unser
verdächtiger nummer zwei war einen neuen
sparten kaufpark alte kaputt war
er sagt man kann gerne im baumarkt
nachfragen hat auch noch länger auf die
pelle bereits kameras nachgucken so
nummer drei der verdächtigen ist die
kleine schwester teresa sie sagt sie war
einfach in ihrem zimmer auch noch gerade
auch netflix die serie house des geldes
geschockt tja wer von den drei liegt
das ding schneidet mir grade folge
sprudel ab also der junge hier wurde
ermordet die beiden eltern waren im kino
das heißt sie sind auf jeden fall schon
mal raus und warum sollten auch in
eigenen sohn ermorden und das sind die
drei hauptverdächtigen wir haben einmal
die hausfrau die noch den wasserspender
auffüllen war dann haben wir den gärtner
der noch irgendein neues gerät gekauft
hat und die schwester die bei netflix
haus des geldes geschaut hat man kommt
da eigentlich eine neue staffel das ding
ist allerdings wenn wir uns medienraum
anschauen sehen wir schon der
wasserspender ist komplett voll und es
ist 10 10 nach zehn nach zehn das bringt
uns aber gar nicht weiter auf grund der
tatsache dass der wasserspender
allerdings komplett voll ist würde ich
sagen dass es die hausfrau war weil hier
sind sie ja noch zu hause und der
wasserspender se noch schon voll wenn
der junge tot ist ja auch noch voll also
die hatte ja nix aufgefüllt es ist
tatsächlich die hausfrau die gelogen hat
und damals eher wahrscheinlich die
mörderin ist denn sie hat gesagt sie hat
eine geschmacksrichtung eine neue für
den wasserspender getauft weil der mal
wieder leer war
die wand ich bin sonderreise alters
ein reicher mann namens arturo geht
eines morgens zur arbeit und lässt auf
dem tisch unachtsam neben einem buch 100
euro schein liegen als er nach hause
kommt ist der 100 euro schein weg in der
zwischenzeit waren nur drei leute im
haus die also verdächtigen das gleiche
rätsel haben wir schon bei meinem
letzten video gemacht ich sage es war
der kellner wenn du wusstest dass der
dieb der elektriker ist dann hast du
einen punkt mehr
das anders ich würde sagen dass wir
dieses rätsel überspringen und direkt
weiter machen mit dem nächsten rätsel
rätsel nummer 32 frauen die sich
überhaupt nicht ausstehen können die
totale feinden sind sitzen auf einem ast
eines hohen baumes
einfach erstmal diese geile
illustrationen hier und da noch die
tatsache warum sollten zwei frauen die
sich über alle kassen zusammen auf dem
ast eines baumes sitzen die einheit eine
säge und sie sagt sie werde das stück
auf dem ihre erzfeindin sitz von ihr
abschneiden ok wird sie herunterfallen
es sei denn sie löst ein rätsel er fragt
okay ich will nicht dass du mich
irgendwie ab sechste schieß los mit
einem rätsel
da sagt wiederum die fragestellerin okay
ich also hanna war vorgestern noch 25
jahre ok und nächstes jahr werde ich
schon 28
sie dumm alltag nur wenige minuten
später nehmen wir mal an heute ist der
erste januar dann war sie vorgestern
also am 30
dezember noch 25 am 31 dezember zum
geburtstag mit 26 sagt jetzt heute am
ersten januar nächstes jahr wenig 28
weil sie hat am 31
dezember geburtstag die frau hat am 31
dezember geburtstag und die geschichte
spielt am ersten januar das yahoo
gestern also im dreißigsten die zehn
jahren noch nicht geburtstag und war 25
jahre geil dann gestern also interessen
diana wurde sie 26 hört und nächstes
jahr will wird sie acht und 28
also so blöd wie ich aussehe bin ich
dann doch nicht
ein undercover ermittler aus london in
england wurde am ort wo er war hinter
einer illegalen ölfirma her okay heute
herausfinden wer der big box hinter der
sache ist er war dem täter wohl ganz nah
auf der spur
deswegen wurde er umgebracht und seinem
apartment fand allerdings auch exakt in
dieser wohnung ein tod von ihm heimlich
notiert wie seht ihr hier gerade
aufgelistet seriöse an hintereinander
die ermittlungsbehörde die kurz vorher
noch mit ihm kontakt hatte wusste dass
jack drei männer im visier hat will oder
morton ich würde einfach mal ganz blöd
sagen dass jede zeit sondern buchstaben
gehört dann haben wir hier a b c d e f g
dann die 1 ist eine null dass er ist gm
[Musik]
das macht gar keinen sinn 7105 ist der a
b c d e f g gg
ig bce gc geht das macht mir das macht
vorn und hinten keinen sinn luca ich
habe ja keine ahnung gerade einem war er
sehr sehr nah auf den fersen und dann
wird er halt ermordet und das ist der
code den er hinterlassen hat für seine
kollegen und der code heißt entweder
bild nil oder morton
ich habe keinen plan als jemand versucht
irgendwie mit dem einfach diesen code zu
entschlüsseln irgendwas ganz kompliziert
ist das ist eigentlich ganz einfach das
ganze einmal rumdrehen nein ergeben die
zahlen ein wort des bosses wäre ich ja
in zehn jahre nicht drauf gekommen weil
ich jetzt halt auch nicht dass er hier
aus der 4 1 h erkennt also sorry wert
darauf kommt der ist echt zu klug für
diese welt rätseln uhrmacher wurdest mal
wieder entführt diesmal wo es zu ändern
und war wieder wurde ich entführt dich
meine fenster schauen diesmal wurde es
ruhig ein unterirdisches labyrinth
gesteckt
du armer kleiner junge hat nur drei
türen die sich angeblich in die freiheit
führen sollen okay doch nur eines die
richtige nummer eins dahinter wartet bis
nach köln zum rennen und auch stießen
jedoch nur wachst ein fuß hinter dieser
tür zu sehr ok nummer zwei ist ein
ritter mit einem schwimmt der jahre lang
geschult wurde nur darauf wartet sich
endlich aufzuspießen also das scheint
ziemlich gefährlich nummer drei
riesiger flug dinosaurier der dass
dinosaurier sterben damals überlebt hat
immer noch lebt und der dich mit einem
feuer strahlt töten wird und verbrennen
wird sobald ich meinen fuß hinein setzen
die hat ja lieber kleiner junge welche
tür will stück zu überleben
was also das nashorn hier wartet hinter
der ersten tür hinter der zweiten tür
wartet dieser ritter der uns aus spitzen
wird und der hier wartete der dritten
tür ein
die dinosaurier der dass dinosaurier
sterben überlebt hat sieht man hier
irgendwie einen hinweis also das sind
wir im labyrinth wir haben sonne hält
flagge dass uns irgendwann helfen kommt
aber wenn ich mich jetzt bin ich würde
eigentlich so aus dem bauch raus direkt
den ritter nehmen weil ich mir dann hat
denken würde herrn mit einem drachen
dino monster kann ich nicht reden mit
einem nashorn kann ich auch nicht reden
und mit einem ritter zur not halt sagen
hey tag ich bin der ich bin echt voll
liebe zu töten ich mal nicht heiße dass
wütende nashorn würde ich persönlich
nicht provozieren nummer zwei der ritter
mit seinem schwert der jahrelang die
schuld vor den würde ich es auch nicht
unbedingt herausfordern nummer drei ist
die richtige tür war um gut ein
dinosaurier überlebt hat gegen schon
realistisch könnte aber natürlich seien
in diesen rätsel sei allerdings
unrealistisch aber ich habe noch gesagt
werde ich mit einem feuerstrahl tötet
ein feuer schreien hat vielleicht ein
drache aus einer sage aber ein echter
dinosaurier selbst wenn überlebt hat hat
kein feuerstrahl
mich verarschen dicker
typisches rätsel man versucht irgendwie
realistisch und realistisches gar nix
eigentlich man versucht irgendwie auf
die lösung zu kommen aufgrund
irgendwelcher begebenheiten und dann das
das passt dann der grund ist warum ist
der dinosaurier ist hey ich hab dich
reingelegt dinosaurier oder gar kein
feuer speien aber das ist es doch
trotzdem noch ein fetter dinosaurier der
mich töten will von den gezeigten
rätseln haben wir das erste richtig
gemacht mit der hausfrau das weiter
haben wir ausgelassen weil wir das ja
schon mal in einem anderen video hatten
das hier hatten wir auch richtig ankam
die umgedrehte zahlenkombination das
hatten wir falsch und das letzte rätsel
mit dem drachen hatten wir auch falsch
das heißt wir haben zwei von fünf
rätseln richtig wahrscheinlich sind
deine eltern nicht zufrieden mit dem
falls euch das heutige video hier
gefallen haben das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da und
schreibt mir bitte auch mal unten in die
kommentare
wie viele rätsel ihr von diesen fünf
rätseln richtig beantworten konnte
und ansonsten wird detektivs das heutige
video zu beenden
abonieren beim einen kanal falls sie
noch kein abonnent sein
[Musik]